[Music]
toward the end of 2020 i caught an
episode of the daily podcast and i was
really struck by the inventiveness of
this particular episode where
they invited their listeners to look
back on that crazy year and then share
their personal experiences by calling
into the show
and i knew in that moment that i wanted
to eventually do something similar
so recently we put the invite out to all
of you guys the listeners asked all of
you to share how this show may have
impacted your life and my team took all
of that
and ultimately crafted what i think is
really an incredible episode and my gift
to all of you
a common misconception is that this show
is simply a platform for the guests that
i invite on the microphone or worse that
it's about me but
when we dig deeper the plane truth
emerges and that truth is that this show
is and has always been
for and about
you the listener
don't get me wrong i love highlighting
the unique individuals that i host here
and i'm as intrigued as anybody by their
wisdom and their experience and i get a
lot out of those conversations but those
guests are in broad terms a bridge to
each of you to the listeners of this
podcast so
while i feel professionally inclined to
serve my guests i also feel personally
inclined to serve you because simply put
without you without you know our
audience these are conversations that
that don't travel that don't have the
same impact and
don't move the needle in lives beyond my
own
so
in a podcast that has traditionally
focused on individual guests the
forthcoming today's episode is a show
focused instead
on yourselves on our unique listening
community and the impact of this
platform
on inspiring positive change in so many
lives because here's the thing
you guys
matter to me it's
why i do what i do
so this episode is really about your
voice your community and these are your
stories and i can't wait to share them
with all of you
right now
good morning my name is karen hi rich hi
rich my name is evan my name is nathan
cadell
um i just want to say hi and i love you
you are my mentor for a damn podcast
i'm sorry if i uh uh
my daily run
i'm out walking the dog right now and i
decided to
kind of be happy guys here
so much gratitude rich i want to thank
you and julie for all that you all have
done today i'm two and a half years
sober your podcast put more plants in my
diet more steps in my day more curiosity
in my mind more resiliency in my soul
and more empathy in my heart
[Music]
hi rich my name is marie and i'm calling
in from cologne germany i am 33 now i
fancy myself the jack of all trades a la
david epstein
uh and i guess a bit of bo burnham too
because i do a little bit of everything
all of the time
i'm tim a 40 year old high school
teacher from switzerland i'm calling
from melbourne australia i'm from the uk
calling from edinburgh scotland edmonton
alberta canada czech republic aloha rrp
team mahalo for the opportunity to thank
you in person for the beautiful gift
you've provided the world
one of the greatly fulfilling aspects of
the podcast saying guests
is that i am not alone
namaste
all the great insights that you and your
guests are providing are influencing and
enhancing my performance as a teacher
parent and husband to let me enjoy my
experience of life so much more
i gave up drinking so i'm nearly two
years sober i qualified as a personal
trainer and i also stopped working for a
well-known sports brand global sports
brand and set up my own corporate
wellness consultancy
i honestly don't know if the new
business will work out i'm two weeks in
i realize though that following my
passion and purpose is something that's
worth trying and fighting for
and my mission is to impact the main
lives by 2025
why because i think everyone should have
the opportunity to live a fulfilling
life and i just wanted to say
failure is not final and we are indeed
you know where we should be
i discovered the podcast in my late 20s
so
rich and team you have seen me through
many life changes
deserting an unfulfilling career in la
birthing two amazing little humans
starting my own translation business
while living abroad in shanghai china
living in singapore for four years and
now back in germany which is my
husband's home country the podcast has
helped play a huge part in keeping my
sanity through all of these major shifts
and upheavals
with peace and intelligent conversation
when
i felt i had no friends or community
around me but throughout the years of
growing up alongside the podcast helped
me realize hey you can make friends and
create community wherever you go all of
our paths are continuously unfolding and
it feels a little less lonely marching
onward with this dynamic podcast as a
soundtrack to this ever-evolving life
i feel an immense sense of community
i am constantly inspired to get out of
my habit of isolation which used to
serve as my safety blanket but through
listening and then reflecting i realize
that old habits can and should be
discarded when they no longer serve our
greatest good
we as humans are meant to evolve we
aren't static beings we're meant to
change and experience discomfort and
grow through what we go through
and we can't reach our full potential in
isolation
although i can't say that i've mastered
the art of accepting change gracefully
just yet
evolution in this lifetime is messy but
i'm getting there
[Music]
so five years ago i went on a date with
my now husband
and within five minutes we actually
began talking about how we loved the
ritual podcast and
about a month later i became plant-based
and
i haven't looked back
you know fast forward to today after
completing a holistic nutrition program
and
attending cornell's plant-based
certificate program i actually
had the courage to open my own health
coaching business that
is really rooted in teaching clients how
to embrace a plant-based diet and
you know
i never thought i'd have the courage to
open my own business
but after hearing so many stories of
triumphs and overcoming your fears and
on your podcast from your
many many guests i knew i had to do this
work despite my fears
your podcast and the impact it has had
on me personally extends outwards to
just so many people in my life that i
love
and it's helping people live
longer healthier lives and and to me
that's the magic of your work and
really
it matters
it truly makes me a little bit emotional
[Music]
so
three and a half years ago
i was at a complete
loss
i was on my way to a rehab unit and i
didn't know which way to turn
and i reached out to you rich on twitter
you may or may not remember
but you did reply to me you replied to
me instantly and that was hugely hugely
inspiring
i was a fan i had read your book at that
stage
but boy did that give me even more
respect for yourself that you would
actually take the time to reply to me
and i'm so grateful for that
now
two and a half years since i have had a
drink which i'm so happy about i've been
inspired by your podcast to start my own
podcast which i did
2018 2019
and it was such a beautiful experience
the main way that i've been inspired by
the podcast is really around decision
making
and the realization that every single
little choice in my life
makes an impact whether on my own life
or
on somebody else's life
so long story short i've always
struggled with my weight and i never
thought that i would one day overcome
that i thought that it would probably
remain something hard for me for the
rest of my life and last year i decided
to make a change i was already vegan but
i started to cut down on processed food
and stick to whole foods as much as i
could like fruits and veg and whole
grains
and it worked
and it was challenging at times because
it requires patience to see results but
overall focusing on consistency
just worked out and
because it has nothing to do with being
hungry and everything to do with making
better choices
it feels like it will be long lasting
and it's just getting easier and easier
so with this transformation i lost 15
pounds in the last 10 months i feel like
your podcast has overall helped me
understand how to invest in the best
version of myself concretely and
although my transformation physically
looks like weight loss it's so much more
profound than that and now i'm ready to
take on new things
to make a very long story somewhat
shorter i used to compete in men's
physique which is the same sport that
your former guest nimai delgado used to
compete in and after competing in four
competitions
my relationship with food was completely
destroyed along with my body image mixed
this in with what i believe is ocd my
mental state after all that was truly
unshameless i looked muscular and lean
but at what cost i completely destroyed
myself and nearly destroyed all the
relationships in my life i was trying to
balance everything in my life around
training where at my worst i would spend
nearly six hours of my day at the gym
between weight training and cardio
sessions
i would train with high intensity to a
point where i didn't consider my workout
to be very good unless i push myself to
the point of nearly blacking out while
training
i also at this time was binging out on
food every weekend to a point where i
would nearly vomit
one thing that i've learned and that i
believe is that our pain our hurts and
our experiences can be used to help
others and actually called in to roll on
a little over a year ago
hey everything adam my name is evan i'm
26 and i live in fullerton california i
asked you about eating disorders and
body dysmorphia among males and your
openness to address the question really
inspired me to share my personal story
and even create my own podcast that's a
great question evan i'm really grateful
uh for this question because i do think
there's plenty of conversations around
eating disorders in females
and it's almost never
discussed
how that dysfunction impacts men but i
think it impacts
tons more than you tons of dudes as time
progressed i came to realize that what i
was doing was not sustainable and i knew
that something needed to give
i remember writing a list of all the
things that needed to change my life
however i just couldn't break the cycle
fortunately for me my wife has family in
australia and at that time we had a trip
planned to go there for about two weeks
this trip to australia was ultimately
what broke the eating disorder cycle for
me i was completely out of my element in
another country and had to surrender
control i knew that my wife's family
would find it odd if i was bitching out
on food or excessively exercising so my
routine was gone and i was unable to
sustain that there and when we returned
to the states it was like a fresh start
i was finally able to repair my
relationship with food and that anxiety
and rigidity no longer had a hold on me
i slowly began repairing my relationship
with food and recently within the last
year i feel i fully repaired it
listening to you and julie interact with
one another reminded me so much of how
my husband eric and i interact
eric died suddenly and unexpectedly in
july 2020 and we were all in shock
we were deeply involved in restoration
projects in our town and school system
greenhouses beekeeping solar and art
installations
all as a way to reintroduce joy and
thriving in our impoverished area in
rural new hampshire
eric's death and the shock that ensued
landed in my body making my legs stop
working for a very long time and my mind
so unclear
at a time when it was very difficult to
talk even articulate what i felt it was
miraculously easy to listen
i found you
i could not think of even one of your
podcasts where there wasn't something
that was helpful in building my own
endurance physical mental
spiritual widowhood is an instant
reinvention of who you are
i'm grateful i had a strong sense of who
i was beforehand i know i've changed
forever
but i also know i can and will heal and
thrive in other ways
i've needed tech talks along the way so
i thank you for the shared stories you
generously provide on the podcast the
rest of us
i will carry on in the projects that
eric started one of which was just
completed installing an asphalt pump
track and trails in the elementary
school where he was the principal and so
pleased about that
i will also continue with my own
projects and passions many music and
writing related
i have wind in my sails often provided
by the stories of fellow learners on
your show i thank you for that
hello rich roll podcast this is tommy
runs i think it's important to mention
that a young black guy from
the detroit area
went sober
then went vegan then started running and
sober vegan runner isn't normally
synonymous with like the black community
so it was just so much different for me
to be going down this road and i was
kind of like on my own with it you know
the veganism is just not a thing in the
black community for real i mean it's
getting better now for sure but at the
time like i didn't know anybody that was
vegan that's black girl that was in my
circle or even close to my circle so i
was just kind of on my own looking for
material and information uh found
finding ultra
and it just spoke so much like to me um
i've been in aaa
and went to the program love the program
program helped me so much in so many
ways that i mean i just i feel like i'm
indebted to those people in those rooms
and those tables so hearing that rich
went through the same process in so many
different ways from a different side of
the world to me um but then also felt
like all the same feelings and all the
same like
just troubles you know it just made me
feel at home reading the book and then
so i started watching the show and
it seems like every time that i was
trying to make a new like direction in
my life
the podcast had a guest on it that was
perfect for that moment perfect for the
past the moment that just passed that i
needed to get over or someone that was
inspiring me to move on to the next step
and kind of reach forward my journey
went from
desperate to
thriving with running veganism now i
have a running company that my own
little personal brand on instagram that
i'm working with companies i've been
able to interview and have a podcast
i've been able to interview some of the
people and have ended up on your show as
well
to
help people just kind of navigate
through these things and through these
times and i super appreciate how much
time you spent on talking about the
black community
and the issues in 2020 that arose and
came back to the forefront so i
appreciate you tommy runs thanks rich
namaste
i've coached swimming for over 30 years
and although successful never felt
comfortable in the role i dreamed of
swimming for stanford university as a
young girl and unfortunately didn't have
a happy ending
i remember the moment when i quit
swimming
when my coach yelled at me
hey do you know why your shoulders hurt
it's because you're too goddamn fat
to this day i remember the shame of that
moment and i think i've spent a lifetime
trying to bolster that young woman who
never forgot the stinging betrayal from
a man
who was respected and trusted to build
me up but not bring me down i've spent
the last 30 years trying to decide what
i'd do with my life i coached while i
was considering this question i realized
at 50 that what i was doing with my life
was coaching but coaching never felt
like the perfect fit that most people
assume despite my success trying to
excavate the why of that has given me
clarity to a question that was much
greater than lack of confidence and
ability
getting a child to swim a certain time a
certain place or qualify for a meet
seemed like striving for something that
felt hollow to me
this result often inspired pressure from
parents stressed for the kids and
decision making on my part that didn't
ring true
listening to conversations on your
podcast has helped me focus on what i
want in this coaching life and it's to
help an individual find things about
themselves while following the black
lines of the pool
to help my kids become the best versions
of themselves an opportunity for a young
person to find out that i am strong i am
worthy i count
i almost felt like there had to be more
it was my desire to make every single
person on my pool deck feel seen and
that they count
finding out that perhaps i am doing what
i was meant to do but i was missing the
purpose but now finding that purpose
each day i tell my kids here you are
someone and here you matter
[Music]
hi rich my name is cameron calm
i was raised in the mormon church
i married a woman and i am gay
i had just kind of denied
myself my sexuality and my truth my
whole life and
i've really enjoyed
the guests you brought on your show it
has helped me as i've learned to embrace
my whole self
as i've learned to accept and be present
as a man and just as a human being and
you've really motivated me to just
make the best of this moment and the
life that we have to live
i've lived most of my life with a
debilitating disorder
called crps or chronic regional teen
syndrome
it's a degenerative nerve disorder in
which i feel pain 24 7.
there is absolutely no break in my pain
and it worsens with any repetitive
action such as writing typing or
physical activities like lifting weights
or push-ups
i struggle to even wake up most days let
alone go to school or have the mental
energy to be present in social
situations
i fought this illness for many years
without any luck of turning my health
around
at rock bottom when i found veganism and
you in 2014 i immediately switched a
whole food plant diet with no processed
foods and i started drinking more water
the biggest thing i took away from your
podcast
and amazing people on it was that my
pain is real but that i could change my
mindset
i started to pursue athletic discomfort
and that has allowed me to
reconceptualize the rpf as soreness
the kind of discomfort that leads to
growth
my favorite thing is i had to make you
uncomfortable otherwise you would never
have moved
i now run 40 to 60 miles on weekends for
fun i box at an mma gym i enjoy the for
a swim bike run perform in dance shows
play around with mastering gymnastics
skills teach spin and practice yoga
daily and i even tried fitness pool
dancing and got pretty damn good
pain is still so real but that struggle
is my engine for growth
life is so so beautiful and you only
have one
but if you do it right
that's enough
sorry to interrupt the flow we'll be
right back with more awesome but i want
to snag a moment to talk to you about
the importance of nutrition the thing is
most people i know actually already know
how to eat better and aspire to
incorporate more whole plants more
fruits vegetables seeds beans and
legumes into their daily routine sadly
however without the kitchen tools and
support very few end up sticking with it
so
because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly and
because i want everybody to experience
some version of what i've experienced we
decided to tackle and solve this very
common problem the solution we've
devised i'm proud to say is the plant
power meal planner our affordable
all-in-one digital platform that sets
you up for nutrition excellence by
providing access to thousands of highly
customizable super delicious and easy to
prepare plant-based recipes everything
integrates with automatic grocery
delivery and you get access to our
amazing team of nutrition coaches seven
days a week and many other features to
learn more and to sign up visit
meals.richrol.com
and right now for a limited time we're
offering ten dollars off an annual
membership when you use the promo code
rr health at checkout this is
life-changing stuff people for just a
dollar seventy a week literally the
price of a cup of coffee again that's
meals.richrol.com promo code rrhealth
for ten dollars off an annual membership
all right
let's get back to the show
about two years ago i was sent to the
hospital because i was having pretty
severe chest pains
my dad passed away from a heart attack
when i was really young so that was my
doctor's primary concern
i was also
in a really difficult season of life
a lot a lot of tough things were
happening and i had fallen into some
pretty unhealthy eating and drinking
patterns to try to cope with some of
these difficulties
i have a son he was one at the time
and i laid in the hospital bed that
night and thought about
what it was like growing up without my
dad
and
in my mind i kept seeing
my son's childhood him growing up and i
wasn't there
and it was right around
this time in this kind of season in life
that i was introduced actually to
rich the ritual podcast and
the memoir finding ultra it was
extremely
transformative to me
it was kind of like
getting to see the story that i want to
have or the place that i want to be in
three years or five years or 10 years
so the doctors told me that one of the
things i could do for my chest pains was
to reduce animal products
and
hearing your story inspired me to go
vegan a few months after i was released
i also knew i needed to get back in
shape
to get healthy again so i started
training for an ultra marathon and i
finished my first ultra
just over a year after my hospital stay
and all this your podcast has really
taught me just kind of the power of the
minds
for so long i
i didn't really think i had abilities to
make changes in my life
it felt like
i just viewed myself as the product of
what happened around me and to me
and
i remember listening to courtney to
walter and
talk about her
mindset shifts that happened during
ultra marathons and recently mel robbins
was on talking about confidence being a
habit that we kind of cultivate and
so many more and i think this is part of
why i started training for ultras and
have continued to do them
you know a couple years on now is just
it gave me space to
show how strong my mind really is and
i've been able to see that to transition
into other parts of my life and i think
coming out of the hospital i knew this
like i knew that was true but i
don't really
think i believed it or at least i didn't
live like i believed it was true
and just hearing so many of your guests
talk about how important the mind is
really made
this reality come alive for me and i've
been able to put a lot of their wisdom
in some of these areas
into practice
[Music]
when i was 28
i felt like i had failed in life
i was overweight working a job that was
never meant for me
and going to college trying to prepare
for another career that was not meant
for me
and just dealing with mental illness
so i talked to an expert in the career
field that i was trying to switch to
and i thought that this was the only
chance that i had to be successful
then it imploded and
i hit the point where i couldn't take it
anymore and my suffering became a
catalyst for change
i had heard this idea of fake it until
you make it
and another way you could put this is
mood follows action
i knew in order to change my current
habit i should emulate the habits of a
person i wanted to be
and i thought one of those habits would
be listening to the ritual podcast
fast forward three years and i have gone
vegan i have lost 35 pounds
and i am training for my first half
marathon
the most surprising thing is that i have
become a harbinger of positive change
for my small family
you say we are conduit
well that's been true for me
my mom has been diabetic since i was a
teenager and has been managing it with a
low carb diet
well i went vegan and one thing led to
another and
now after a year of eating an almost
vegan diet her a1c is down so much that
they are talking about taking her off of
metformin
and if you know anybody with type 2
diabetes you know that's a big deal
i watched my grandparents live with
diabetes and something that scared me as
a child was that no one ever went off
medication once they went on it
so this is really incredible and i am so
grateful i have been telling people if
your heart is true the universe will
conspire to support you
and it really has for me and i'm still
in the process of transforming
four years ago
i thought i was gonna be a rock star but
i was a bartender who drank with a death
wish every single day i had two duis i
was about to lose my marriage
and my health was really really bad
so bad that i ended up in the hospital
with acute pancreatitis for 10 days
immediately after getting out of the
hospital i quit drinking and then
very soon after that i tried veganism to
heal my insides from the pancreatitis
and i tried to absorb all things vegan
and i ended up listening to one of your
podcasts
i found it so relatable you and i
couldn't have more different backgrounds
but so many of the things you said about
sobriety and veganism and health and
family just really ran true to me
and i couldn't stop thinking about it
and your book made me sign up for my
first marathon
which i ran in four hours and 15 minutes
and every single one since then has been
uh just a little bit better
that was four years ago i'm four years
sober now four years vegan and i never
thought my life would look like this and
the gratitude is just unbelievable
life as i knew it shattered when my
health collapsed just before my 21st
birthday
i went from being an accomplished honor
student and collegiate varsity athlete
to a bed bound college dropout treatment
after treatment failed
for the next several years my physical
health continued to dissolve under the
weight of unbearable chronic pain and my
mental health soon followed suit
during an extensive inpatient hospital
stay
i stumbled upon a podcast hosted by a
guy who really liked plants
what i thought was a podcast that would
teach me about veganism was a podcast
that would end up fundamentally changing
the lens through which i view life
on the most difficult days i would cling
to stories like those of taria pitt
whose life shattered in an instant and
who overcame the seemingly impossible
challenge of rebuilding her life
i recall the episode with matthew long
who after nearly dying
experienced an awakening and found his
purpose of helping others
these interviews among many others
taught me that i am not special in the
best way
i am not the only one to have my life
entirely dismantled
our journeys may not parallel each other
in the type of terrain that we had to
cross but they certainly reflected each
other in the sense of what you can do
when you feel like you have nothing left
this podcast taught me that within
uncertainty lies potential
and it helped me cultivate my belief in
a better tomorrow
as i did this my physical recovery
gained momentum
i eventually returned to college
graduated with highest honors and
secured a full-time job
i even went back to playing competitive
sports
i did all of this motivated and inspired
by the ritual podcast the entire way
i have stepped into my purpose of
enacting change in the healthcare system
dismantling the stigma that surrounds
chronic illness and female pain
and advancing pain research
the compelling conversations of the
ritual podcast truly ushered me into an
era of self-evolution where i thought
all hope was lost
as mary kane so eloquently stated
i don't want to rewrite my story
i want to make something good going
forward
i am 34 years old i am a husband and
father of three from indianapolis
indiana i have always felt that my life
is very typical in cookie cutter
i felt that i was the epitome of average
a five foot nine middle class white male
living in the same town i was raised in
with little hope of experiencing
anything exciting or making an impact in
2015 i had a great job loving family but
the daily repetition of life left much
to be desired and caused me to go into a
depressive state
feeling guilty for not feeling satisfied
i began searching i stumbled across
several life-changing podcasts that i
couldn't stop consuming on my commute to
work they changed the core of my being
caused me to realize that i am a unique
human worthy of love and exploring and
experiencing life
my low empathy levels were rocked during
some of the podcasts causing my heart to
break and need to be
ugly crying in my car on my commute to
and from work
this was weird for me because i had only
found empathy for my wife and kids prior
to listening my heart rarely broke for
those less fortunate realizing that i
wasn't alone in this journey of the
human experience was so humbling and
anxiety reducing
hearing it from a guy who had real life
struggles that we all have
it made the podcast genuine the guests
were real people with real stories that
exposed me to a broader life outside of
my small midwestern bubble we began to
take ownership of our life i quit my job
and pursued a job where i knew i was
making a difference for humanity we
began to invest in rental properties and
pride ourselves on developing lasting
relationships with our tenants helping
them on their journey of life
it's my wish that we can all be part of
this journey in some form or fashion to
be loved and to give that love to others
my story began about 10 years ago when i
lost all three of my sisters within two
years of each other
they were all very unexpected deaf but
they were all health related
it was shocking because we
enjoyed a lot of healthy longevity in
our family our grandparents and parents
lived into their late 80s and 90s my mom
passed away at 95.
around that time i started to just ache
from head to toe and i know a lot of it
was grief but a lot of it i believe you
know was being brought on by something
else so finally i went to a doctor and
was diagnosed with bone leo arthritis
i've never been one to immediately jump
to medicine i always look for a natural
way to solve my problems first so that's
what started my deep dive thinking that
even though we had all lived healthy
lives we thought something was clearly
not right so i started with the
documentary fat sick and nearly dead and
i did numerous 10-day cycles of a juice
fast
and started to feel a lot better and
about three years ago i got introduced a
podcast and actually rich your podcast
was one of the first ones and through
your podcast i have read so many books
and i'm very healthy i feel great and
when i retired my daughter and i decided
we would open a healthy fast convenient
restaurant we wanted something that had
the convenience with a kids player and a
drive-through but that would supply the
community with healthy nourishing food
we were able to find an old building and
in february 2020 we opened
we were open for a month and had
fantastic response from the community
because in our town of hagerstown
maryland a restaurant free range cafe is
the only healthy option
30 days later the pandemic hit
our restaurant did survive the pandemic
and we are still open today we were able
to pivot very quickly to
online ordering and delivering food to
the car and we've been very successful
so i guess i'm really happy i'm happy
the way things have worked out but we
just are still in a place where we
haven't figured out how to make our
restaurant profitable and to grow it
because we would like to grow it to
multiple locations and franchise it and
hope that someday
healthy convenient fam-friendly food can
be in every community where now food
swamps are the norm
i was stuck in life i was in a loop i
kept repeating the same patterns and i
couldn't get out of it i come across the
ritual podcast i'm watching it
all day every day because i quit my job
and the biggest thing that i learned is
the power is within
mindset is everything and no we can't
just
snap out of a mindset but it's training
yourself seeing all these people who
took themselves from the bottom to the
top
the thought was why can't i do that
i'm often questioning myself in the
meaning of my life and wonder if i'm
missing the boat am i contributing
enough to this world or could i give
more am i growing where i've been
planted and is this enough
sometimes i dream of being seen and
recognized and contribute with who i am
to help and serve to a larger platform
and then
i appreciate what i have and feel a deep
gratitude for my life as it is
i keep showing up in my life connecting
with compassion and humility
on a daily basis i tend towards being a
better version of myself
having you as guides by my side
instilling strength courage and hope in
the possible
my story starts on june 11th 2016.
on that day in the morning my husband of
25 years who i loved told me he was
cheating on me
later that same day in the afternoon
five of my grandchildren and my
son-in-law
fell over the letter state park falls in
new york
everyone made it out except dylan who
was nine and preston was six
and that all happened
in one day
i basically lost everything in my life
i lost my house my husband
my grandchildren
relationships over that situation
which is a very sad story
but yeah when i share it with people i
share it because
i try to give
people who are going through a hard time
hope
because i worked very hard and decided
early on
that i was not going to
let this ruin the rest of my life
and
your podcast has helped me tremendously
even though
people
face
trials in life it doesn't mean life is
over
it means we have to fight in order to
have our right
to be happy in this life
my transformational story is my last bad
day
i got hit head on by a ford explorer who
crossed the center line of the road
going 40 miles an hour
and i broke a whole bunch of everything
doctors don't know how he survived
let alone back riding
this year i had my left knee totally
replaced and next year i'm going to ride
my bike across the country to celebrate
21 years since my last bad day
filled with gratitude kindness love
three things i think the world needs
more right now because i'm only here
today because
of those in my peloton as i like to say
and so through your podcast
it's been one part inspiration another
part of motivation
and also some discovery
what's comforting about the podcast and
all your guests coming at it from
different angles is just
all the fortitude all the strength all
the grit that's within us
when we shift the conversation that we
have with ourselves and surround
ourselves with people who bring out the
best in us
we can do almost anything in fact i
would say we can do anything
i call my last bad day my last bad day
because if i have my wife and my
daughters and people who bring out the
best of me i can't call a whole day a
bad one yeah i have had some tough
moments we all have especially going
through this grand kerfuffle that we're
living in but through gratitude through
a lot of different things that you talk
about
i know that
i have building blocks to create a bear
tomorrow and your podcast helps me keep
rolling helps me keep pedaling
hello rich this is kathy just outside of
ottawa canada your podcast has changed
my life
i started listening to you on
recommendation from a friend in may 2019
when i was on a sobriety journey
for the past 10 years i've been living a
mother's health my husband and i had
adopted two boys ages 3 and 18 months in
1995. everything was good in the early
years and i truly believe that nurture
outstripped nature i was naive the early
trauma came to a head in their teenage
years where everything went off the
rails getting kicked out of school drugs
crime disappearing incarceration
violence you name it as i leave you this
message my youngest son is a meth addict
and is living on the street
i became a daily drinker drowning myself
in a bottle of wine or more a day
i was still functioning though holding
down a big job but i was dying inside
the only thing that was keeping me going
was my horses i don't think people knew
the extent of my drinking problem or the
pain i was in the phone would ring i
would jump i had so much anxiety
it came to a head in 2018 when i had to
sit through a trial where my youngest
son had been accused of horrific crimes
including sexual assault it was
traumatic i couldn't manage it anymore
i needed help
i sought counseling and then i found
your podcast
your own personal journey and the
journey and insights of your guests
expanded me it was like all the dominoes
were falling in the right direction
and i figured out i could not stop their
suffering
it started with your first podcast which
validated my decision to get sober went
sober i had clarity of mind and
everything else seemed to fall into
place
i started journaling took up yoga
meditation and started to focus on being
mentally healthy and i let go
covet hit i quit my corporate job and
continued on a journey of healing and
letting the universe tell me what to do
through your podcast i expanded to a
place where i found my purpose
i was now on our farm full-time i could
spend a lot more time focusing on my
horses and their amazing gifts
i then reconnected with a friend that
was working with children at risk using
equine therapy
my purpose hit me i was meant to do
therapeutic work with horses as
facilitators using my own experience
with my children addiction and trauma
i've started my formal training
i know this is my path i will be
launching an equine assisted therapeutic
business in 2022. horses are amazing
facilitators and mirrors of our souls
who would have thought of 60 years old
that i would be doing this
my story is i have neurological lyme
disease i became completely bedridden
for two years but i gained a lot of
wisdom insights and gifts from this
illness it forced me to no longer run
for my problems i was a raging alcoholic
from 14 to 26 and my mom was
schizophrenic
and i did some deep self cultivation i
laid in bed for two years i read books
and i listened to podcasts this is where
i got turned on to rich roll
i really liked the one of edward garcia
i believe the chef who lost his arm and
the man who got bit by a shark main
thing i learned from this is that our
adversity our suffering is actually an
opportunity to rise to the occasion and
become the best version of ourselves
around the time your podcast started i
found myself
diagnosed with an autoimmune that had no
cure and no treatment
and i had been vegan a year and a half
worked out six days a week just
incredibly healthy turned 40
and i ended up in a wheelchair
and i was in that wheelchair for five
years
went through a stem cell clinical trial
and got better
and all of this has been since 2012 so
the stories
the conversations
it's all just been a guidepost for me
um to listen to and be encouraged as
i've taught myself to walk again use my
hands and
get out of the chair and
you know re regain life
so to speak and the lessons that i've
learned being present getting through
the difficulties and being told no by
world world-renowned hospitals that i'd
never get better and there wasn't any
hope
it's just been
really
encouraging to hear the stories of even
though i'm not an athlete some of these
athletes that have you know really been
told no as well so i thank you for
putting all the goodness out in the
world and um
hopefully my little story will help you
keep going because it does matter
so i've been living in the north of
spain and i had like one of the worst
years of my life it was rainy dark i had
no money no friends i was hung up on an
x toxic mold exposure in my apartment a
full body rash
but i made it through and i was gonna
fly home for the summer was stopped in
barcelona to visit some friends and
there my hero of over 10 years anthony
bourdain killed himself
and i was shattered and i flew home
and spent all my money on the ticket to
get back to michigan needed to buy money
for rent then on my third day in
michigan there were flash floods in my
town and one of the only victims was my
12 year old cousin
and it was the hardest funeral ever and
a few days later we had a family get
together and i broke my phone and it was
the last straw
so for like 36 hours i had suicidal
ideation
but i needed to go to work on monday
morning and i was teaching kids and they
helped break those negative thought
loops
and then on my bike ride home i listened
to a ritual podcast with julie
where rich and julie were talking about
their most difficult time
and getting cars repossessed and all
that and julie used this line this is my
divine moment
and it hit me and that's that time i
needed to hear it and i started to
repeat it and felt better you know this
is my divine moment
it's not happening to me it's happening
for me
and yeah the podcast helped me gain a
lot of trust
my youngest brother justin died of a
heroin overdose
[Music]
on wednesday
december 5th of 2018
driving to rockford illinois with our
dad
to identify justin at the hospital the
following day was a painful experience
so many miles so much painful silence
seeing my baby brother in the er
incubated and gone was one of if not the
most traumatic experiences of my life
he was so handsome
his hair so freaking amazing
he used to rub it in my face all the
time his beautiful thick wavy hair as i
complained about mine thinning with age
all i could do standing next to his
lifeless body was run my hands through
his hair and kiss his cold forehead
i was genuinely heartbroken and at that
moment all i could do was drop to the
floor and stop i just sobbed
uncontrollably
i literally couldn't believe i was
looking at my baby brother dead
you don't ever wipe a memory like that
out of your mind and for the next 12
months it would literally haunt me every
day
at the end of 2019 i was drinking
alcohol in an abusive way numbing the
pain from drowning in grief over losing
justin and our mom just two years prior
in fact i suffered many losses in the
years leading up to justin's death two
miscarriages a marriage and a uterus to
be exact
i knew the way i was handling what life
was throwing at me wasn't sustainable
but more importantly i didn't want it to
be
and i knew only big changes would create
significant results so i created this
challenge in my mind that i would run
one 5k every month for a year until i
could do that without stopping to walk
i also committed to something bigger my
annual dry january would be a dry 2020
instead yes i was giving up alcohol for
an entire year
i was committed to changing my life
story and set out to transform myself
from the inside out i was determined and
felt unstoppable
over the past two years i have found a
lot of purpose in my pain and it has
changed my life listening to your
podcast and the wide variety of
characters and life stories you've
unveiled has truly helped me get here
from november 2019 to the end of 2020
through a global pandemic no less i
managed to run 19 races most of those
were live if you can believe that and
the last three were back to back half
marathons the last of which i ran
straight through without stopping to
walk even one
living a great story while i'm here on
earth is my goal every day i want to be
the person who looks in the mirror every
day and feels pride i am that person
today and i'll do my best to be that
person tomorrow too i hope you do too
[Music]
so
there you have it that was the beginning
of the story of the rest of my life the
follow-up is that i did introduce
alcohol back into my life this year
after my usual dry january but this time
it was different
unlike past years where i just go back
to drinking and i don't think about it
this time i've done it with a keen
awareness because after being sober all
of 2020 i had something tangible to
compare my life to
and what i've concluded beyond a shadow
of a doubt is that my life is just
exponentially better without alcohol
playing any kind of role
i am definitely not a have a glass of
wine with dinner and don't drink for two
weeks kind of gal i'm just not
so for me labeling myself has become
irrelevant
what is relevant is that drinking is
like hitting the mute button on my life
and being sober is like turning the
volume up to 10 and i am definitely a
turn up the volume type of person
so after a year-long soul-searching
mission i've committed once again to
sobriety but this time my goal is a
lifestyle choice not just a year-long
challenge
december 5th will no longer just be the
day justin
died december 5th will also be the day i
chose to live
to make a long story short i was born
and raised in eastern north carolina
my whole family were farmers they sold
out to factory farming i moved to
asheville north carolina
i started getting in trouble when i was
15 years old in and out of prison from
to age 30.
now currently on ultra pipe and plum and
we have ultra coffee bar here in
asheville north carolina
it's complimented to you and named after
finding ultra
started doing physical endurance events
about three years ago always worked out
my whole life i started doing physical
endurance events and really dived into
your podcast out doing some rucks
started running i'm actually running now
and heard this spot on you and ms
philly's podcast and wanted to just call
in
started my first orchard race last year
ran 76 miles in combat boots they had no
idea what i was doing
this year i've ran 200 80 miles 72 miler
and 350 miles and have 100 miles come up
on december 4th
kind of started running listening to
your podcast and haven't looked back
been really successful in my businesses
sobriety's been great asheville's been
great every day is a blessing to be
alive man and so grateful for you guys
and
y'all inspired me to get out put my
shoes on every day and get out and run
since i started listening to i learned i
can do hard things i can get up at 4 a.m
i can exercise in a snowstorm
last summer i climbed my first 14 or 14
000 peak
and uh
i am no robbie ballinger but for someone
to start climbing at my age i'm 66 i
mean it was daunting but i made it and
that taught me i could do other hard
things and
for the first time in my life i really
understood how challenging my body and
the
structures that go along with that has
given me the confidence to challenge
every other part of my life and not wait
to be in the mood to do things and i use
that mindset now with everything i do i
just act first and
the feeling usually comes along later
i can't finish without saying my
favorite guest which was steven
pressfield i love him i listened to the
war of art and i can honestly say that
your conversation with him and his book
has helped me finish writing my third
book
we feel inspired
challenged by your podcast and
keeps this fire lit inside of us you
know trying to
be the best humans have the best impact
on this planet while we're here you know
leave no stones unturned for looking at
self-reflection for how we can be better
in
all aspects of our life and it's been a
real game changer you know we don't get
a lot of exposure and kind of are
isolated at times in our
communities and our circles
due to the current nature of
the pandemic and just in our thinking
not everyone thinks like us and so
having a community that we can turn to
and listen and get these ideas from
these great thought leaders it's just
been amazing for us so
you know we really appreciate it and
wanted to thank you guys and yeah please
keep it up and
we'll continue to try and do our part
and
share
the
information and
be great stewards of this beautiful
planet and
that's it thank you so much
i want to say hello to rich and adam and
julie i feel like i need to address all
three of you i have wanted to call into
roll on actually so many times but i've
never really had a question
i just wanted the opportunity to say how
life-altering this podcast has been for
me
my name is kim johnson i'm 47 years old
i'm a musician and music teacher and my
story starts with my dad
we spent hours together on long training
runs that was my special connection to
him he trained me for my first of many
half marathons during my 20s and 30s and
he ran all of them alongside me and he
was well into his 50s and he was always
kicking my ass
the year he turned 59 he had
a really weird fall during a race which
had a super concern that something
wasn't right and at the young age of 60
we discovered that he had parkinson's
disease
the disease quickly took a toll on his
ability to train long distances and i
was
also getting busier with a young family
and that special connection naturally
began to fall away
he fought hard for the next seven years
and then on the night of june 22nd
in 2015
he fell actually right near his bed in
the middle of the night
which immediately left him paralyzed
from the neck down
the only prognosis doctors could give
was to be in a bed in full-time care
facility with a feeding tube a breathing
tube with a trach and the whole deal
what was so interesting about this whole
situation is that he was a pastor
and he had visited people in the
hospital all the time over so many years
and had literally seen everything
because of this he had a very specific
medical directive drawn up that said if
all these things that were about to
happen were going to happen he didn't
want to be kept alive
and he said take the feeding tube out
take the ventilator out and let him pass
on his own or as julie would say make
his transition
he passed seven hours later at 3am on
the 4th of july a day that marks freedom
ironically
it is still the most spiritual beautiful
and holy moment i have ever experienced
but i returned home the day after my
41st birthday
and while standing on the blacktop of
the school i was currently teaching
music and my two children were attending
i had my first panic attack during the
flag salute
this began my journey of learning how to
cope with anxiety and depression along
with radical amounts of transformation
that were going to take place over the
next five years
and your podcast popped up in things you
might like
even after searching i still can't
remember which conversation i listened
to first but i just remember thinking
who is this guy who is so openly
vulnerable
i hadn't heard anyone talk like this in
this space and i just slowly began to
drink up these conversations i'd been a
singer my whole life it was always part
of my livelihood i had transitioned from
public education to teaching music in
the private sector
and although it helped a little i was
incredibly unfulfilled and couldn't
figure out why
and so frustrated as to what to do about
it i really believed that i wasn't any
good at it when actually i hadn't tried
hard enough for long enough
now we were in a lockdown and i might as
well give it all the attention while i
can
and around this time you and adam had
started roll on
i kept hearing the message said in
different ways by different guests on
repeat about a practice a little bit
every day over six months a year two
years can make such a big difference
the conversations rich would have with
julie i mean if two people could be any
more different and stay together i sure
as hell could make my marriage not only
work but evolve and become more healthy
she was helping me come to grips with
patterns that were no longer serving me
anymore
and i'll never forget the episode
oh gosh
where she shared about trevor and
trapper's dad passing
and the first time i've ever heard
uh death reframed to making the
transition
was so beautiful um caroline burkel
helping me realize that the trauma i've
experienced is real and it needs to be
attended to alexi helping me think about
our brain is also something that can
have
injuries that need time and treatment to
heal just like a physical injury stephen
pressfield i had read already do the
work three times and already was so ants
when i found out that rich was going to
talk to him
his reminder
that resistance is a real force and that
wow i just have to keep giving it the
middle finger
every day
every single roll on since the day it
began listening to adam talk openly
about the struggle that it is to show up
for himself
working on his novel the conversations
with dr ayashi and dean sharzai
someone who could give first-hand
information about some of the good
things that really went on in
afghanistan
so such a beautiful rich truthful
conversation
my insides began to open up and songs
began to take shape
it became the way i processed my dad's
exit from this earth so suddenly and
whatever was happening to me and around
me and in the world
i began
feeling brave enough to put myself out
to whatever local venues would let me
come play pushing myself to increase my
major skills as a guitar player and
pretty soon my perspective began to
change my countenance begin to change
and just like my workouts had always
been my lifeline to sanity songwriting
became a necessary part to my existence
rich's conversations were in the
background of all of this
every time i woke up wanting to give up
i'd pick up a podcast and get back to it
[Music]
you know no man is an island
and the impact that you have had
is not just on the people sending in
these messages it's not just on the
people who listen to your podcasts
it is exponential you have impacted not
just me
but my family members who have gone
plant-based every single one of my
clients my patients that i work with and
that is true for every person that
listens to your podcast
so thank you for that
the ones and zeros nourish my soul and
reverberate through my life
tina my fiance and i want to thank you
julie and the entire rrp community for
what you create
the journey is only beginning and we are
filled with gratitude
while pursuing what is in our hearts
oh my gosh there's so many ways i can't
[Music]
even tell you like
how much you guys
have begun to feel
like true friends you know friends that
i don't actually i'm not actually able
to call you up and
talk to you about my things and get your
opinions about my things but
um i've really come to look forward to
the show every week
and i actually can't remember
which one of your podcast guests said
this but use the acronym
roi as ripples of impact rather than
return on investment
and um i think when i started out
coaching i was way more concerned with
the return on investment you know what
can i get out of this
versus
what impacts can i make on others and i
think about that a lot and i try to make
sure that i never lose that perspective
in why i coach
really at the end of the day i think
your story is what's most impact it's
beautiful
and i just love how you've taken all
your pain and transformed it into
beauty so just keep doing what you're
doing
and uh we just love what you're doing
and i'm just so grateful that um i found
you
keep up the good work keep doing what
you're doing much love and gratitude to
you
thanks so much you guys enjoy the day
truly um thank you so much
thank you for having the courage to
strive for healthy change in our
confusing and beautiful world
peace
[Music]
namaste hope all of you enjoyed that
found it meaningful and receive it and
the spirit in which we offer it
which is really a spirit of gratitude
and i have to say it was
it was very emotional for me listening
to all of you and i want to end this by
sincerely thanking you
especially all of you who submitted
voicemails
and of course to every single one of you
who is listening to this episode
the gratitude and the pride that i feel
after hearing all of these stories is is
really just beyond anything that i could
adequately articulate
this podcast is a labor of love for me
and has always been my gift to you but
today
all of you gave me a gift and that's a
gift i will not soon forget so thank you
thank you for your courage
for taking the leap for calling in and
and being vulnerable and for walking
this journey alongside me
thank you for putting wind in my sails
and and and for giving me hope in the
good but most of all
thank you for letting me serve because
it is in service
that i find purpose that i find meaning
and a sense of
deep satisfaction that positively
infuses every aspect of my daily life
experience
i can't overstate the extent to which
your experiences humble me and hold me
accountable for my own actions
inspire me to do and be better and
ennoble me to soldier on in the face of
whatever obstacles i may face
in closing i want to be very clear that
i'm not looking to take credit
whatsoever for anybody's journey so any
improvements that you made
in your life to your life is on you
entirely
hats off and head bowed in reverence and
i just love hearing the stories it helps
me feel more connected to you it helps
dry the cement on this community bond
that i'm trying to foster
a bond over just being better because
giving back
is what it means to be part of a
community
so i sincerely hope you enjoyed this
episode as much as i did if you're
inclined to support the podcast the
easiest and most impactful thing you can
do is to simply subscribe to the show on
apple podcast on spotify and on youtube
i would also appreciate it if you would
consider sharing this special episode
with your friends or on social media
and for podcast updates special offers
on books the meal planner and other
subjects you can subscribe to our
newsletter which you can find on the
footer of any page at richroll.com
finally i really want to thank my team
for crafting this episode they did all
the work here and it was a tremendous
amount of work but it paid off they did
such an extraordinary job
the episode was produced and engineered
by jason camiolo and dan drake and the
video edition of the show was created
again by dan drake and blake curtis
graphic elements were courtesy of daniel
solis and our theme music as always was
created by tyler piatt trapper piett and
harry mathis
thanks for listening see you back here
soon peace